الفعل ساعات وتفصلنا عن الذكرى السنويه
لانطلاق العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
كما تصفها موسكو او الحروب التي يعني تجري
في المنطقه في اوكرانيا بالفعل المحور
الشمالي من مقاطعه هو الاكثر سخونه حيث ان
القوات الخاصه قوات فاجنر باتت تدخل في
عمق مدينه باخمت وتدفع القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب من عده جوانب اهمها الاجانب يعني
الناحيه الجنوبيه حيث دخلت الى مجمعات
سكنيه كبيره وسيطرت على مجمعين في الناحيه
الشماليه واعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الروسيه دخلت من الناحيه الجنوبيه عده
كيلومترات بينما
الناحيه الشرقيه حسب تصريحات مؤسس
قوات فاغنر بان القوات الخاصه دخلت الى
مناطق معامل اللحوم وشقت الطريق التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني وتمكنت من
السيطره على عده نقاط كان يسيطر عليها
الاوكرانيون اما الناحيه الشماليه فقد
سيطر بالكامل على بلده بريخوفكا الجيش
الروسي او قوات فاجنر وتقدم الى بلده اخرى
بلده ياجرنه ويحاول السيطره عليها قتال
شوارع في جميع المحاور الشماليه والجنوبيه
والشرقيه هنا نائب او مستشار القائم
باعمال الرئاسه في مقاطعه التابعه لروسيا
قال بان الجيش الاوكراني ربما ينسحب في
الوقت القريب واكد ان السيطره على باخموت
ستعلن في فترات قريبه
يصادف اليوم راويه يوم المقاتل السوفيتي
الذي
انتصر على النا في تلك الحقبه الزمنيه في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه تشهد المدينه
احتفالات ربما بطابع فردي لكن بالفعل وسط
هذه الاحتفالات والتهاني سقطت عده صواريخ
وقذائف يعني اطلقت القوات الاوكرانيه على
قلب المدينه استانفت قصف المدينه من جديد
وكانت الدفاعات الروسيات الجويه تعترض هذه
الصواريخ بعض منها اعترضتها والبعض الاخر
فقط هذا الحديث من نصف ساعه تقريبا ولا
معلومات عن اصابات وضحايا حتى الان لكن
لابد ان هذين اليومين اليوم غدا سيكونان
ساخناني بالفعل نظرا
لاهميتهما التاريخيه ايضا لا بد من
الاشاره الى ان المعارك الدائره في يعني
مناطق اخرى من مقاطعه المحور الجنوب حول
مدينتي مارينكا ايضا فيهما معارك مستمره
استخدام لاسلحه متطوره حديثه